or you know artists so  i mean that place goes crazy  you're like oh  he's versatile  are you talking about your athleticism  tell me the three most athletic guards  in the league right now and you  obviously can say yourself yeah i'm  definitely i'm number one though  you're number one who's two  athletic cards  i'm gonna honestly go with ant-man  okay he i feel like he's really athletic  uh  get off the floor pretty fast  um  zach levy  mm-hmm okay  that's for once you can actually more if  you want are you good what you yeah i'm  number one but i'ma just you know pick  three so  so you're number one and then anzac or  jumble you know who people forget about  i think because we haven't